I ask you of these different phenomena
UFOs covid global warming and nuclear
Annihilation which one is keeping you up
at night the most they're all of them
the most no I mean look I'm not supposed
to say I called it but we're insane just
the swing nuclei problem within the
space of the time that I was talking
about it we're facing potential absolute
cataclysm you know we're now funding
more Eco Health Alliance we're trying to
figure out if we should be sending
planes after sending tanks into Ukraine
we're not supposed to discuss it nobody
knows what's going on I don't know what
we're doing but I do know that we're
playing Russian roulette and we're not
going to be surviving this if we keep
playing this every time somebody wants
to change a border in Central and
Eastern Europe
[Music]